Florida in the crosshairs of Hurricane
Emma the storm now is a category four
with the winds of a hundred thirty miles
an hour but is expected to strengthen
Irma is so large it's expected to hit
Florida's east and west coasts the
Hurricanes projected path has shifted to
the west in the past 24 hours
Irma will travel up Florida's Gulf Coast
and by Monday reached the southeast the
storm battered Cuba as a category 5
hurricane late on Friday
Irma is being blamed for at least 21
deaths and catastrophic damage
throughout the Caribbean this morning
our most outer bands are lashing South
Florida and the keys with wind and rain
Jeff Glor leads our coverage from Miami
Jeff good morning Dana good morning - so
we are just off this game Bay here on
Bayshore Drive in Miami you can see in
the distance
hopefully the bridge which is 195 which
is the one of the main thoroughfares
between the city of Miami and Miami
Beach and South Beach we've already seen
here some changing bands of intensity as
Emma moves closer it was calm before the
broadcast it got nasty for a little bit
with some high winds and some rain and
then it's calmed down just a bit but
obviously that will only increase in
intensity as we move along here we do
want to take a look at Emma from space
if we can because we do have some video
that was recorded just before noon on
Friday as the International Space
Station flew about 250 miles over the
hurricane which was then a category 4
storm since then it strengthened to a
category 5 last night before weakening
again slightly to a category 4 and as
you mentioned the leading edge of this
storm is already affecting parts of
South Florida including where we are
also the Florida Keys and Elaine Quijano
is in Florida City just south of us here
Elaine good morning good morning to you
Jeff well I can tell you Florida City
the homestead area is known as the
Gateway to the Florida Keys
behind me is overseas highway also known
as Route one the only way in and out of
the Florida Keys and just a short time
ago we actually saw what
here to me some kind of transport
basically it was a convoy of what appear
to be school buses escorted by state
troopers making their way from the keys
some kind of transport out of the
Florida Keys as the evacuations continue
even at this hour now in terms of what
we felt it's a little bit of a lull
right now I can tell you though in the
last 90 minutes or so it was not like
this we saw some very intense wind some
very intense rain and lightning so
severe in fact one strike actually hit
not too far away from where we're
standing right now so this is a storm
that residents here in particular are
watching very carefully because their
memories of Hurricane Andrew are very
vivid it was decimated this area when
Hurricane Andrew hit and now they are
watching these skies very very nervously
Jeff away thank you very much